TREY: WELCOME BACK TO
"SUNDAY NIGHT IN AMERICA,"
VLADIMIR PUTIN THREATENED TO
USE NUCLEAR WEAPONS IN WAR
AGAINST UKRAINE AND CALLING
UP 300 THOUSAND RESERVISTS
THIS MILITARY WHICH IS
CAUSING PANIC AND A MASS
EXODUS FROM RUSSIA.
AS LOSSES MOUNT WILL PUTIN
BECOME MORE DANGEROUS.
WHAT THE COUNTRY THAT
GAVE US CHERNOBYL DISASTER
BE CAVALIER ABOUT WEAPONS
THAT COULD DESTROY THE WORLD
COULD ROBERT O'BRIEN WAS OUR
TOP HOSTAGE NEGOTIATOR
MR. AMBASSADOR THANK YOU FOR
JOINING US, HOW SERIOUSLY DO
YOU TAKE PUTIN'S THREAT TO
USE THEM?
>> I THINK WE HAVE TO LISTEN
TO THE DICTATORS WHEN THEY
MAKE STATEMENT LIKE THAT AND
BE PREPARED.
WE DIDN'T LISTEN TO PUTIN
WHEN HE SAID HE WAS GOING TO
UKRAINE, AND HAVE NOT LIT
LISTENED TO CHAIRMAN XI IN
ABOUT GOING TO TAIWAN.
I THINK THAT COMMENTS ABOUT
USE OF NORTHBOUND
NUCLEAR WEAPONS AND
MOBILIZATION ARE INDICATIONS
THAT RUSSIA IS IN TROUBLE,
THEY ARE LOSES AND PUTIN IS
TRYING TO FIGURE OUT HOW TO
CHANGE THE EQUATION.
THE GOOD NEWS IS THAT
UKRAINE IS WINNING THE WAR.
>> LET ME PLAY A CLIP FROM
PRESIDENT ZELENSKYY AND YOUR
REACTION ON THE OTHER SIDE.
>> HE WANTA TO SPARE THE
WHOLE WORLD.
THESE ARE THE FIRST STEPS OF
HIS NUCLEAR BLACKMAIL.
I DON'T THINK HE IS
BLUFFING.
I THINK THAT THE WORLD IS
DETERRING IT AND CONTAINING
THE THREAT, THE UNITED
STATES COULD SHOW ITS
LEADERSHIP POSITION AND
RECOGNIZE RUSSIA AS A
SPONSOR OF TERRORISM.
TREY: ALL RIGHT, I'M SURE A
LOT OF AMERICANS SAY, WE'RE
TRYING TO HELP.
BUT WHAT WOULD SAYING RUSSIA
IS A SPONSOR OF TERRORISM
ADD TO IT?
SHOULD IT BE DONE?
IT, IT HAVE BEEN DONE IN THE
PAST?
>> I'M NOT SURE THAT IS WHAT
WE NEED TO DO, WE NEED TO
BACK UP OUR DETERRENTS WITH
A STRONG AMERICA, PEACE
THROUGH STRENGTH WORKS,
RONALD REAGAN SHOWED IT
THROUGH MANY YEARS OF THE
COLD WAR.
AND SHOWING RUSSIANS WE'RE
NOT BE BULLIED OR PUSHED
AROUND OR BLACKMAILS, IT IS
THE UKRANIAN PEOPLE WHO HAVE
BEEN FIGHTING AND DYING, WE
NEED TO MAKE SURE WE'RE
ENERGY INDEPENDENT THAT WILL
KEEP PUTIN FROM TRYING TO
PUSH US AND OUR ALLIES
AROUND, AND
ASKING EUROPEANS TO PITCH
IN.
AMERICAN TAXPAYERS ARE THE
MOST GENEROUS IN THE WORLD,
I SAW GERMANS SENDING 4
ARTILLERY PIECES THAT IS NOT
RIGHT, WE NEED THE EUROPEAN
ALLIES TO BURDEN THE SHARE
WITH AMERICAN TAXPAYERS AND
GIVE THE UKRAINIAN ARMY WHAT
THEY NEED TO FIGHT THE
RUSSIANS AND PUSH RUSSIA OUT
OF UKRAINE AND SEND A
MESSAGE TO BEIJING, THIS IS
YOUR FATE IN TAIWAN WHEN YOU
TRY TO INVADE TAIWAN, THIS
IS AN IMPORTANT TIME IN THE
WORLD WE COULD SEND AN
AMERICAN IMPORTANT MESSAGE
-- IMPORTANT MESSAGE BY
STANDING UP TO RUSSIA.
TREY: YOU SEEM TO BE DRAWN
TO THE TOUGHEST ASSIGNMENTS
IN THE WORLD, THE NATIONAL
SECURITY ADVISER BUT ALSO
YOU WERE A HOSTAGE
NEGOTIATOR.
LET ME ASK YOU, HOW DO YOU
NEGOTIATE FOR RELEASE OF
AMERICANS WHILE NOT AT WAR
BUT CERTAINLY INVOLVED IN A
WAR THAT COUNTRY IS
INVOLVED?
HOW DELICATE IS THAT
CONVERSATION?
>> IT IS DELICATE YOU HAVE
TO SHOW STRENGTH IN
NEGOTIATIONS, LET THE OTHER
SIDE KNOW YOU ARE PREPARED
TO WALK AWAY.
YOU WILL NOT OVERPAY
FOR HOSTAGES AND CREATE A
MARKET FOR THEM TO TAKE NEW
HOSTAGES OR ENCOURAGE OTHER
COUNTRIES TO TAKE HOSTAGES
WHETHER IT IS IRAN OR RUSSIA
OR CHINA, WE NEED TO FIND
OUT WHAT THEY BUSINESS AND
LOOK FOR -- WHEN THEY WANT
AND ARE LOOKING FOR, IF IT
IS REASONABLE.
WE HAVE TO LET THEM KNOW,
WE'RE NOT ALLOWING AMERICAN
NATION INTEREST
SET ASIDE FOR THE SAKE OF A
HOSTAGE, WE HAVE GET THEM
OUT IN TRUMP ADMINISTRATION
WE GOT OVER 55 HOSTAGES FROM
THE WORLD.
GOOD TOUGH NEGOTIATING AND
IN SEVERAL CASES WE USED THE
MILITARY TO GO IN AND RESCUE
OUR HOSTAGES, THEY ARE THE
BEST IN THE WORLD, WE NEED
TO LET THE EVILDOERS THERE
IS A PRICE TO PAY WHAT YOU
HOLD AMERICANS.
>> AMBASSADOR ROBERTS
O'BRIEN.
THANK YOU FOR YO